first question from lisa marie hey
michael
i have a problem at work i recently
moved to a new city for work and have
not fully
settled in there is a guy at work i have
a crush on but there are a few
complications
he is much younger than me i'm catholic
and he's a practicing jew
and i am about five inches taller than
him do you think this is too much of a
divide to be bridged
does height and age really matter thanks
a lot
sincerely romeo and not a
juliet well done
well done not a juliet
there are a lot of complications here
not the least of which
you don't even really get to it or
acknowledge it but
not the least of which is you work
together so if things don't work out it
could be a little bit awkward
it could be even worse than awkward uh
so you know you got to take that into
consideration plenty of people meet at
work so i'm not i'm not saying
that's a deal breaker but something to
consider in terms of the
age it could be an issue the only the
only way it would be an issue
necessarily is with kids
i think i mean you know age creates
complicated i've i've friends who are
married who have big age gaps and it can
be a problem it's not always a problem
but it can be
but with kids it could really be a
problem because if if
the timing is not going to work out and
he really wants kids then
probably this thing isn't going to work
for you as for the religious issue
if you want to be married and remain
catholic you know if you want if you
want to be married in the church
then you would have to agree to raise
children catholic that's the way that
you would get a dispensation from the
bishop for an interfaith marriage
and really really he would have to
convert
right because you you need to be unified
you can't have a family that believes
radically different things like that
and if the man is going to be the head
of the household which is pretty
traditional then if you're not going to
convert to judaism and
as a fellow papist i would suggest you
do not do that
then you would have that trick and
that's not impossible plenty of people
start out believing different religions
and they come together but but
you'll either grow together or grow
apart
not saying you can't go get a drink with
the guy in terms of the
height you know if you don't have a
problem with it he doesn't have a
problem with it then who cares you know
think about nicolas sarkozy the former
prime minister of france
who you know he was dating that hottie
who was much taller than him and that
was made him look like an even cooler
guy so that i wouldn't worry about that
but
uh and in terms of you know in terms of
the age it's there
that is a little bit more difficult than
it than it would be
in terms of height but you know you
could suss it out you don't need to
decide whether or not you're going to
spend your lives together on on the
first date
but you shouldn't drag it along either
and put yourselves in a bad situation
that'll be harder to get out of so hello
there
oh i barely noticed you came in you
might not notice that i come in
to your computer if you don't ring that
bell if you don't like and you subscribe
because then you won't get the
notifications youtube already
doesn't want you to see the videos that
we put out so make sure you ring the
bell right now
we'll see you next time
you